says Vince well hold on man what are you
saying I haven't even introduced Our
Guest yet you may remember our guest
though from this marvelous little clip
from Vice statistically it is true that
Asians right on average make more money
like in terms of medium make more money
better test scores get into better
colleges all that stuff I think the
question is why is that and I don't know
if model minority whatever that label
wants that's actually a Miss because we
cannot be um well no listen well let me
finish my point we need to observe what
makes people successful and unsuccessful
and I think when you look at trends that
are generally true in the Asian
Community not of everyone but are
generally true usually you have families
that are sticking together you have
um you know people are taught to work
hard in school not get into trouble I
think that translates to why Asians on
mass are successful and I don't think
you have to be Asian or white for that
matter to not have kids out of wedlock
not you know commit crime not not cause
trouble or whatever it is it's just a
matter of like well common sense that's
what makes people successful and if that
so-called assimilation having a nuclear
family buying a house going to school
whatever it is then yeah okay call me a
pro assimilation then I think there's a
difference between assimilation and
Erasure yes
yeah Vince how come you told people not
to commit crimes and to get married and
don't have kids at a wedlock you you're
trying to erase culture you're probably
a white supremacist Vince Dow for those
who don't know 19 year old conservative
YouTuber and influencer from Florida and
just a destroyer of Libs with both facts
and logic in that Vice documentary Vince
thank you for coming on the show
yeah thank you for having me Michael
it's great to be here it's funny I am
19. and it's kind of a trip because I
grew up watching you and you were
actually one of the people originally
that kind of broke me out of my
libertarian phase and then now here we
are in the show so uh you know they say
never meet your Heroes but I think
you're all right thank you I am so
pleased to hear that because when I saw
your clip there which was just
absolutely phenomenal and I look at some
of your other commentary
I I sensed that I sensed that you were
not just another young guy spouting the
same platitudes that we've all heard for
30 years about hey do whatever you want
just don't make me you know pay for it
and uh
Live and Let Live and all that no you
actually seem to have more of a vision I
can't help but notice that you got to
cross behind you there on your wall and
that your focus is less on
licentiousness and permissiveness and a
little bit more on virtue and a little
bit more on what allows people actually
to flourish absolutely and you know like
I said on that panel societies don't
come together and form because they have
nothing in common they share No values
they have no commonly accepted sense of
morality they form and we build
communities and we make smaller
covenants with their own lives you know
we make friends we get married we build
relationships based on things that we
have together and all I essentially said
on that panel is well you know this is
to be the rule the rest of society too
this is how every society has had to be
built in human history and it's really
funny that that's the clip that went
viral that one you just played because
my comment about that being assimilation
was semi-sarcastic in the sense that we
just had a whole prior debate about this
very topic you know about you know the
greater concept of assimilation and
because I think there's a lot more to
assimilation than just saying hey be a
functional member of society hey don't
commit crime right like assimilation is
much bigger you gotta acclimate to
culture customs things like that but
because we just had that debate I kind
of like you know casually say well if
that's assimilation okay call me such an
evil bad person then and you see how
that one girl takes it 100 absolutely
seriously and is like not committing
crime that's Erasure you know because
you imagine that's a fairly low bar for
assimilation is um yeah right respect
the laws
um don't go to prison on this because
there is as you say there's a little bit
more it's the language that we speak
it's the rituals that we engage in it's
the the way that we view ourselves
individually and the way we view
ourselves as a culture but that bar is
so low my main question watching that
whole panel is they were all Libs they
were some of the most expressive Libs
I've ever seen I mean they're they look
like Jim Carrey in the 90s their their
eyes got so wide the moment you said oh
my gosh Asians do well on on academic
tests oh how dare you say something
that's manifestly true and and so I I
just wanted to know how'd you even get
on the panel so they reached out to me
uh via email and it's kind of funny
originally we were supposed to do a
masculinity panel I assume they just
found me because like conservative
social media whatever
um but they originally interviewed me to
do a masculinity panel it's really funny
Vice decided Well because I was Asian
let's put you on the Asian panel instead
which is fine I think it worked out for
the best because I saw the masculinity
panel they did it was kind of not that
interesting whereas the one I was on you
know very spicy a lot of people so I
think it worked out but uh that that was
a funny part of it and the other part
was uh I don't know if I'm supposed to
say this but whatever origin if you look
the date the panel came out it was
December 14th originally it was supposed
to come out on December 7th you know
December 7th of course the anniversary
of Pearl Harbor and uh they at the last
minute noticed that and decided to pull
it but I was I was kind of hoping they
put it out on December 7th because it'd
be kind of funny and it would be but
yeah that's what happened so there are
some backstories behind a day that would
live in infamy for all of them who were
on that panel no no question about it so
you you come out there you make this
point about
just noticing just observing that Asians
more than other immigrant groups and and
I guess really more than any other
demographic in the country tend to
succeed and so maybe they're doing
certain things that other groups should
emulate and that this is uh totally shut
down so let's say for a second you had
people on the panel who were a little
more uh sophisticated where would you
then take that discussion about
assimilation well then I would you know
take it further to suggest that
um I think when you look at the current
state of America there's this kind of
debacle of
I say assimilation but I think there's
more to what I say than that because you
could also make the case that the people
on the panel were assimilated right and
what are they assimilating to Liberal
culture right the cultural Marxism
Satanism whatever that currently runs
our system and say hey hey Vince hold on
are you observing are you suggesting
that at one of our largest cultural
events of the Year many very elite
people including the first lady of the
United States would clap at a literal
depiction of a Satan dancing around
jiggling with transsexuals are you is
that the kind of thing you're you're
suggesting you conspiracy theorist yeah
I know that makes me a crazy conspiracy
theorist science denier uh white
nationalist all of it right
um
but no yeah as I was saying so I think
that
you know to quote Donald Trump or
paraphrase him you know I think in many
ways we have to kind of shut down the
system until we can figure out what the
heck is going on right and I think this
is the the issue and I think this is
intentional that the left does is that
they're bringing in you know millions of
immigrants every year legal and illegal
and either they don't assimilate to
American culture and you just have a
very divided nation Etc or they do
assimilate to American culture but most
of them assimilate to mainstream
American culture which is like left-wing
culture and so you know where I kind of
was hoping to ultimately take the
discussion is I think in many ways
America needs a restriction or a pause
on the current immigration levels right
obviously the southern border we talk
about that all the time but also you
know in terms of the legal immigration
system we have very big numbers coming
in
um his much historically higher than
they were at other points in American
history and there's been no pause right
historically in America we've had these
waves of immigration but then there's a
pause there's time to assimilate since
1965 it's just been Mass unrelented
immigration both legal and illegal and
it's creating this country where nobody
needs to assimilate and if they do of
course because you know our enemies are
in power they're assimilating to the
things we don't want them to assimilate
and so if I were to have a higher level
discussion I would say yes obviously it
is true
um in order for a society to stick
together we have to have common values
and culture and all that stuff but then
I would also say
that can exist in the way the system is
currently being structured right we need
to a fix our culture and then maybe
after that we can talk about what we do
with immigration but so long as we're
bringing people into this country then a
telling them not to assimilate which is
a problem or B telling them to
assimilate to the culture of New York
City and Hollywood it's just a disaster
and it's a disaster for us politically
culturally spiritually all of it so
that's a really great point because
conservatives throughout my lifetime
have always said no assimilate
assimilate assimilate but if we're going
to assimilate to Sam Smith you know
dancing around like a a sort of devilish
looking lesbian saying Go Daddy to the
body shop and do whatever you know I
don't want that kind of assimilation I
actually I I think we need to assimilate
to some of the cultures coming here as
long as they're not worshiping the devil
so that's a really great point and your
point on legal immigration is so
important too because even president
Trump and you know I love the guy and he
did a lot to move the conversation on
immigration but he said I want more
legal immigration than ever it just
can't be illegal it's got to be legal
and I sort of think of of the three
positions on immigration as uh tired
wired inspired you know the tired
version on immigration is open the
Border let everybody come in no human
beings illegal borders are awful right
then the wired version is we got to stop
the two million illegal immigrants that
are coming into our country every year
but then the inspired version is well
hold on we're also taking a million
legal immigrants every year and we have
for the past 60 years and it's the
largest movement of people ever in
recorded history and nothing against
those people but how is a country
supposed to just take in three million
people a year without any assimilation
and maintain anything representing a a
coherent Nation I just don't see how
that's even possible yeah and it's funny
because people always say well you're
like Vietnamese
you've just got that ethos to you you
know I don't know it's some of the
spirit you know I always say like my
brains probably come from the Vietnamese
side and then just my speaking you know
like my person it's it's totally hands
the hands are Italian
um but you know they always bring that
up and you know it is true right some of
my family not all of them some of them
came as a result of the 1965 immigration
system but you know it's like I'm an
American right and I think it's actually
incredibly selfish to say well my family
benefited from the system therefore the
rest of America has to deal with that
system till the end of time like people
always frame it as oh you're like me
you're not compassionate I am
compassionate I'm very selfless for my
own country because I was born here
right so I have no political ties to
Vietnam or Italy I have political ties
to America and so it's my job as an
American Patriot to look at what's going
on in our country and Advocate what's
best for the people in this country not
some hypothetical caricature of uh you
know people who might be like my family
out there I mean you know God bless them
but my duty as an American conservative
American Patriot is to look out for
Americans and I think when you look at
the current system objectively from that
lens it's very hard to make the case
that this system works right the only
case the lips can ever make is like whoa
but but but you know my family were
immigrants you're an immigrant it's like
but that's not an argument right we're
talking we live in this country we have
to do what's best for this country not
what's best for our own in-group
interests or what's best for again a
hypothetical caricature of someone who's
like us so I love the way you flipped
their slogan on its head because I've
heard this slogan too you know half of
my family comes from the Mayflower the
other half comes from a sardine boat and
the Sardine boat side you will sometimes
hear from my more liberal friends and
family members they'll say Michael it's
so selfish of you some of your ancestors
were able to come in through immigration
it's very selfish of you to say that
other people can't come in through
immigration but what you're saying is no
what is selfish is claiming that's
simply because you and your family have
benefited from a policy in history that
may at the time have been relatively
fine but now is having deleterious
effects that simply because of that
because of your own sense of the
privilege that you therefore have to
inflict a really harmful political
agenda on the rest of the country that's
what's selfish yeah absolutely I mean
you said it you said it best right there
I don't know what else to say that's
that's a really uh really good take and
I think a really way to shove it right
back in their face I got a call the
other day from a very prominent
politician who I did not know before I'd
never spoken with him before and he was
just sort of calling some people to get
a sense of what Young Americans are
thinking and so I I said one of the more
surprising aspects of the youths that I
meet going all around the country
college campuses you know I'm in my mind
I'm still a ute myself but in reality
I've become an old man with two children
and a wife living in the suburbs and so
when I talked to the real youths
I see a phenomenon that is the opposite
of what a lot of people in Washington
think a lot of people a lot of
Washington politicians believe that the
the youth are very libertarian they're
much more libertarian on drugs on
immigration on sexuality and family just
everything they just do whatever you
want to do and I said guys you're really
misunderstanding that that may have been
true 10 years ago the young
conservatives that I talk to and
especially the ones who are getting
traction who are having a voice people
like you Vince
they tend to be a little more concerned
with virtue not merely the freedoms that
we could have in in the abstract but
what we are called to do with those
freedoms lest we undermine the entire
political order is that a fair
assessment I think that your average
kind of frat guy who maybe like votes
Republican doesn't like or not votes but
which would be a Republican or doesn't
like Biden they're more libertarian but
I think there is you're correct the type
of people that would show up to an event
like yours and be engaged in the system
there is this like three percent five
percent or whatever that yes is very
concerned with virtue because we have
grown up entirely in a society without
it right and I think a lot of older
people they still remember the America
of the 50s and the 60s with the white
picket fence and all that and and but we
have been we have been raised in a
society so depraved The Virtue that yes
we are seeking virtue and Order morality
in these things and I think even if
we're a minority in the generation
because we are the most active and the
most passionate and some would say the
smartest I don't know you know many
people are talking about it many people
are saying this that's really how you
know political movements Revolutions in
a peaceful sense uh begin is they don't
begin from the masses they begin from
like the founding fathers they begin
from a small group of Elites who really
have the right or sometimes the very
wrong idea in mind that are like driven
committed passionate and they end up
being the ones with the voice and the
change and this is the issue with the
left too right is I don't think your
average gen zero is like the kids on
that panel but your average political
liberal Democrat one is because though
they're the loudest people their most
vocal most passionate involved people
but I think when you look at our side
and you know the people in our
generation who are most involved with
conservative politics and things like
that I think they're absolutely the
people you described and so when we talk
about moving the Overton window and kind
of what our generation of conservatives
is going to push for I think you're very
accurate on that front and I love the
observation that the people who actually
move the needle in politics
it's almost never the majority of people
I mean for good and for ill the
Bolsheviks pretended that they
represented the majority that's why they
chose the name Bolshevik but they were a
fringe minority of radicals and they had
a huge impact and and you see this
throughout history you see this with the
people who began the French Revolution
you see this with the people who began
the American Revolution you see you see
this always with political movements
it's a very uh concentrated core of
people who are committed to an idea who
have a political Vision because as you
point out a lot of Frack guys I'm not
knocking frat guys some of my very best
friends are frat guys okay but but a lot
of people just don't pay very close
attention to politics if if right now
you are listening to this interview you
pay more attention to politics than
probably 99.3 percent of people most
people kind of want to do their jobs see
their families maybe engage in a little
Recreation go fishing watch some TV go
grilling with their friends and they
don't want to deal with the intricacies
of whatever stupid thing Elizabeth
Warren is saying that day as fine I'm
not knocking that at all it's probably a
healthier way to live frankly but as a
result of that if you are not deeply
engaged in politics
you are just not going to be the the
person who is leading the revolution
right where whereas the when I go to
college campuses I I agree obviously
there's a huge number of people who say
hey what what's the big deal with
marriage what's the big deal even with
gender
but the people who are articulating
coherent questions
on the left and the right for that
matter I mean certainly on the right but
even the leftists they have crazy views
on all of this stuff but at least
there's
a kind of coherence to their bizarre
illogic those are the people who really
have the Clear Vision and they're the
ones who have let the men into the
women's bathroom and they're the ones
who are going to kick the men out of the
women's bathroom if we're so lucky to
have that so we've only got about a
minute left Vince but you're very young
you're very articulate you've got a very
clear political Vision now you have a
little bit of promise what uh what are
you aiming at for the country if let's
say tomorrow the 75 Republicans who are
currently running for president drop out
of the race you find yourself in 1600
Pennsylvania what would you do
that's a good question I think the first
thing I'd have to do and maybe this is
where we kind of in a sense agree with
the small government types quote unquote
is I think in order for a conservative
politician to get anything done at the
federal level we have to like destroy
the Deep State the bureaucracy and for a
while I kind of was like well maybe we
could use it in in our own favor we
could use it for ourselves and then it's
like you know the more I thought of it
like who built this stuff FDR LBJ you
know the P like it was always designed
to work against us and I think in many
ways it's that Federal bureaucracy
that's just causing a lot of different
problems for this country and so I would
say you know there's a lot of like I
guess powerful base things that I want
to do but I think the first thing we got
to do is really like drain the Deep
State Fire all these people and then
maybe once they're all out of the way
then we can talk about using power uh in
our favor to our advantage that's what
I'd probably say and then at that point
you know
um let's let's you know let's bring
manufacturing back to this country let's
try to somehow solve the problem of
fixing you know the family cry Isis
let's you know cut immigration until we
can figure out what the heck is going on
a lot of ideas but I would say first
thing I try to do is get rid of the deep
State that's going to stop all those
ideas and very doable to people who are
going to accuse you of being Pie in the
Sky especially on like the family issue
well how on Earth is the government ever
going to fix the family issue I would
say look at Hungary Hungary actually has
done that it's the one confidence we
could start with just uh trying not to
destroy the family I mean that's a good
start right stop the bleeding first Do
no harm that's that's right right and
and to your point on the bureaucracy
it you know the federal bureaucracy is
something like two million people and so
in in order to have any effect on it at
all you would have to replace at least
50 000 people and the the actual uh
Replacements that occur in presidential
administrations about four to five
thousand so we're nowhere near that
right now the principle of subsidiarity
of having decisions made at the most
local level at which they can be done
competently it's very conservative
principles very Christian principle and
and then even to the point of wielding
the bureaucracy to our advantage I'm not
saying it can't be done it has been done
in the past but to your point you gotta
fire like pretty much everybody to do it
and back when the conservatives did
wield the bureaucracy in a way that was
sometimes uh successful they did so
through the spoils system they did so
through replacing that bureaucracy
pretty regularly and so I think I think
you're absolutely on to something Vince
and I think you've said it very very
well and I think you totally owned those
Libs most important of all I think you
totally uh and which is really important
because as I've always argued when we
own the libs we have to own the libs for
a purpose and it's to show people that
the ideas that they're offering are are
a total failure and that the vision that
we have to offer is clear enough that it
can knock down all that piffle pretty
pretty quickly you did that very very
successfully Vince where can people find
you uh you can find me on my YouTube
channel it's just my name Vince Dow Dao
and then you can find all my social
medias too from from there but YouTube
channel probably the main thing I plug
all right go follow events everybody I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you